no I get it anybody myself included can
call themselves a bloggers or
journalists and just put up their own
yeah and and have no sort of merit to do
that I guess what I'm saying is any
advice for that in-between time where
you kind of say to yourself Wow was this
my peak because I think there's a scary
moment and and so much of la is you're
only as good as your last whatever oh
yeah and so how do you deal with that
well that's that's that's a scary thing
it's just I must say it's a scary thing
I mean you are always looking to top the
last film you have or whatever your
project is or if you're a comedian your
last set if you're a musician your last
show it's it's you have to always strive
for that you're not going to try it you
don't try to match the last one you try
to beat the last one you know because at
least you know you've put you put your
all into it I that was a big deal with
this film because the fact that we had
to actually we didn't we was half the
budget less than half the budget of my
previous film tangerine was less than
half the budget of starlet then all of a
sudden we found ourselves shooting on
the iphone it got to the point where I
think in some some people's eyes we were
going to make a film that was less than
the one before but see I I read one
review that actually kind of I'm
affected by reviews and I am I'm sorry
that's as me and there was one review
that said that starlet was less
ambitious than Prince a Broadway which I
didn't agree with but that did affect me
so this film was intentionally more
ambitious than starlet or at least high
attempted more ambition so so yeah I'm
I'm vulnerable that way what can you do
but but i did but but but they're
getting back to the iphone thing but it
does relate to what i just said because
i won't say who said this but somebody
said this when i asked them to come work
on tangerine and i say
were shooting on the iphone and this is
after i already had convinced myself
that it was okay they said okay Sean
y'all come to LA and play with you and I
said no no no you can't use that word
play please don't use that word play
because if we look at it that way we're
going to fail from day one you know we
have to look at this film as just as
important as anything else we're doing
and we have to strive to make this thing
as good if not better in the previous
one so the play word no we're not
playing here that was so so that but
that always at that that way of thinking
has to be applied to every film out
there you know
you